hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast mechanisms of crisper cast
systems from adaptive immunity to
biotechnology presented by dr. de Pauly
Sasha top assistant professor Department
of Biochemistry biophysics and molecular
biology Iowa State University i am
xavier gutierrez of lab routes and that
will be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots lab roots is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen our speaker will
respond to your questions via email if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
conceived on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
de Pauly I will now turn the
presentation over to her Thank You
Xavier I'm really happy to be presenting
today on some of the basic biology of
crisper cast systems so I think a lot of
people are often very familiar with
Christopher casts because of the bio
technological tools but as you can see
on the left
one of the major interactions that
occurs in on earth really is the
infection of bacteria by bacteria phages
and CRISPR Kass is actually derived from
an immune mechanism that allows bacteria
to fight off those phages by serendipity
Krister caste systems are really useful
as well for biotechnological tools that
you can see summarized on the right so
today I'm going to talk mainly about the
importance of these crisper caste
systems in fighting off infections in
bacteria so some of the basic biology
behind these systems so I wanted to
start a little bit by talking about
bacterial infection and I think often
when people think about a bacterial
infection they think about bacteria that
are infecting our bodies or animals or
plants but here what I'm actually
talking about is the infection of
bacteria by viruses so just like any
other life-form on earth by bacteria and
archaea are subject to infection by
viral particles and of course for
bacteria we call those viruses bacteria
phages so on the left you can see a
micrograph of a bacterial cell which is
on the bottom that's being infected by
these phage particles which are all of
these smaller circles on the top and
this type of interaction the infection
of bacterial cell by a virus is
something that occurs an astronomical
number of times every day
so it's estimated that there are ten to
the 31 phage particles on earth that's
ten with 31 zeros after it
so really a number that's almost
impossible to fathom this is actually I
believe ten orders of magnitude larger
than the number of galaxies that are
predicted to be present in the universe
so just a really really large
astronomical number and this is really
estimated based on the number of
bacterial particles that are thought to
be on earth which is about 10 times less
than that so the typical bacteria 2
phage ratio is estimated to be around
one to ten and even though we've known
about sages for over a hundred years now
and they've been the subject of intense
study we've really only scratched
the surface of what we understand about
phages thus far you can see that a very
very small percentage of stages has been
characterized to date and so there's a
huge amount of information out there
that we still have yet to uncover in
terms of phages as well as their
interaction with bacteria and because of
the prevalence of phages and the fact
that they really are the most abundant
life forms on earth bacteria as well as
archaea have developed diverse defense
mechanisms to fight them off and one of
those defense mechanisms is CRISPR Cass
CRISPR Cass is what we call an adaptive
immune system what that means is that
the immunity is actually provided
through some type of molecular memory of
the infection so if you think about the
human adaptive immune system humans of
course have B cells and T cells which
produce antibodies and t-cell receptors
that can recognize very specific
sequences from an infectious agent such
as a virus or a bacterium and those
cells are specialized to recognize
specific types of pathogens
similarly the adaptive immune system of
bacteria also have specific interactions
against the pathogenic agent and those
are stored as molecular memories within
the host chromosome so the specific
memory is actually stored within a locus
called a CRISPR array which you can see
in the circular chromosome shown at the
top and that CRISPR array is made up of
repeating sequences which are shown as
black diamonds and those are separated
by sequences called spacers which are
unique sequences you can see these as
different colored squares those spacers
are actually derived from foreign DNA so
they can come from bacteriophage DNA
they can also come from plasmids or
other mobile genetic elements but
they're essentially short snips
of DNA that have been snipped out of a
foreign DNA a foreign genome and
inserted into the CRISPR array this
occurs upon infection of the bacterium
by the phage when a matching spacer is
present against a particular phage this
spacer provides immunity so you can see
here that the blue sorry the green and
the orange spacers are providing
immunity against the green and the
orange phage from which the spacers were
derived what's interesting about the
CRISPR caste system is that it is
adaptive which means that new molecular
memories can be acquired upon infection
by a new phage that the host has not
already encountered so in this case
let's say that the host was infected
with this red bacteria phage you can see
that there are no run spacers present in
the CRISPR array however what can happen
over time is that some of the bacteria
in the population can acquire a new
spacer in the CRISPR array and this new
spacer now provides a memory of the
infection and provides immunity against
that phage so CRISPR caste systems
vaccinate hosts against specific
pathogens through the acquisition of
spacers within the CRISPR array so I
want to talk a little bit about how this
actually works in the first step of
CRISPR community the process that I just
described to you is or occurs and this
is what we call adaptation so this is a
process by which genes that are
associated with a CRISPR the so-called
caste jeans or CRISPR associated genes
which form or which are translated into
proteins that are involved in the
adaptation process so these caste
proteins can sense the infection by a
foreign DNA and snip out a short piece
of that DNA and it's
as a spacer in the crisper array so in
this case these adaptation proteins are
snipping out a blue piece of DNA and
inserting it into the CRISPR array next
the CRISPR is transcribed into what we
call a pre crispr RNA this is a long
crispr RNA or long transcript that
contains all of these repeating
sequences and all of the spacers between
them the precursor RNA is processed to
form short CRISPR rnase in this process
within the repeat so what that results
in is that each of the crisper RNA the
resulting CRISPR rnase contains a
separate spacer sequence and of course
each of those spacer sequences matches
some piece of DNA from a foreign element
these can combine with other caste
proteins to form what we call an
effector complex so this is essentially
a complex that's going to use the crispr
RNA and is going to act as the effector
for the crispr RNA and what it uses it
for is to of course find the
complementary region within the DNA from
which the spacer was originally just
derived so upon finding that the cast
effector complex can unwind the DNA and
allow for the RNA to base pair with the
matching sequence in the DNA following
that target binding the target isn't
cleaved and this leads the degradation
of the target and thus the
neutralization of the infection so if
you don't have DNA you can't have an
infection event so this is the overall
mechanism by which CRISPR community
works and I'm sure many of you are
familiar with the process that's shown
on the right what we call it
interference this is of course the basis
for genome editing because we can
program an effector complex such as kes
9 with a guide RNA that matches the DNA
sequence of interest and because Casa 9
contains intrinsic endonuclease activity
it will cleave that DNA the matches to
the CRISPR to the guide RNA sequence and
upon repair
the DNA break that is caused by this
cleavage you'll have some kind of change
that occurs within the DNA so that's the
basis for genome editing using CRISPR
systems so I want to focus in on one
part in particular of this mechanism
because this part is very very important
in order to understand how the
interference mechanism actually works
even though this part is very important
I've only depicted it in this overall
picture with a single arrow which is
shown in the circle but what's really
happening during that step is that the
effector complex is searching the vast
amount of DNA that's present in the cell
in order to find the potentially only
one single complementary sequence that
matches to the crispr RNA so this is a
very daunting task because not only is
there foreign DNA in the cell but of
course there's also the bacterial
chromosome which in some cases can be
hundreds to thousands of times larger
than the piece of DNA that it's actually
searching for and there's really nothing
intrinsic intrinsically different
between the chromosome and the foreign
DNA that it would allow the kasih factor
to focus its energy and searching just
the foreign DNA so it kind of has to
search all of this DNA in order to find
that sort of needle in the haystack
so how is this achieved this is a very
complicated process well it's the Casa
factor actually simplifies its process
by instead of searching for these long
pieces of DNA searching instead for a
shorter segment called a pam that's
located just next to the target site so
I'm going to show you this in the next
slide so the Pam is a sequence that's
located next to the complementary region
of the target this is not actually
complementary to the crispr RNA it's
simply a sequence that the Casa Factor
uses to search to simplify its search
mechanism when looking for the
complementary region so the
complementary region has to be next to a
pan the Casa fector can simplify its
search by only looking for
complementarity next to regions with the
pan so here you can see a target with a
pan located adjacent to it the Casa
factor initiates the target unwinding by
first interacting with the Pam this
allows the Casa factor to interrogate
the adjacent sequence for
complementarity with the crisper RNA so
it begins unwinding in a directional
manner away from the Pam and if a
compliment is present this allows for
base pairing between the crisper RNA and
the target this means that the first
several base pairs that form what we
call a seed region are more important
than the base pairs that form further
away from the Pam
so this pam proximal region of the
target is very important to ensure that
you're going to have high affinity and
fast binding of the Casa factor to the
target if a full complement is present
then this crispr RNA DNA duplex will zip
up as is shown on the right and this is
what we call an R loop this is the final
form of the Casa factor bound to the
double-stranded DNA so I've told you
that the Pam is very important and the
seed is very important for target
binding and one thing that can happen
during a viral event or in a viral
infection is that you may have some
phages that have accumulated or have
random mutations somewhere in their
genome just due to replication errors
that can occur if a phage is more to it
and fortuitous enough to have a mutation
in the Pam or the seed region this will
block binding of
has effector to that target and
essentially lead to escape of that phage
from the immune system so as a result
the pam and the seed are often sites of
escaped mutations in bacteria phage so
this brings up an interesting point
because Casa vectors have to be specific
right you have to have some specificity
for the target sequence because if you
don't have that specificity the Casa
vector and the interference mechanism
could potentially be toxic to the cell
you could have situations where the cast
effector is binding to the host
chromosome and is affecting interference
against the host chromosome which would
lead to autoimmunity however so that
would be the situation that's shown in
the middle where you have low
specificity that could lead to
autoimmune effects on the left we can
see a very high specificity situation
where basically everything that's
occurring is only occurring at a perfect
target with a perfect Pam and a perfect
seed and a perfect entire target
sequence this is also not ideal for a
crisper cat's immune system because if a
system is very highly specific it's much
easier for phage to escape from it so I
mentioned that you can have escaped
mutations in the Pam and the C but not
all mutations are necessarily equal to
each other and so Casa vectors have to
have some relax in the relaxation of
their specificity in order to stave off
too much too much escape from occurring
and so the fidelity of Casa factors is
really finely tuned or at least that's
what we think to be more in the medium
range in a range where some mutations
can be tolerated but too much difference
between the Chris
and the target sequence is not is will
basically cause rejection of the of the
target so medium specificity allows
broad targeting targeting against phages
that has mutate mutated or phages that
are closely related but not identical to
the phage from which the spacer was
originally it was derived but at the
same time limiting toxicity through
autoimmunity so this is a question that
my lab has been very interested in how
is the specificity of CRISPR caste
systems tuned and also what other
mechanisms are there to mitigate the
issues that can arise from having
mutations within the target so in my lab
we've studied several different types of
CRISPR caste systems you can see from
this diagram adapted from a review that
was published in science a few years ago
that there is actually a lot of
diversity in the interference machinery
that's present in various CRISPR caste
systems and as a result we've actually
divided CRISPR caste systems into two
different classes called class 1 and
class 2 so the class 2 systems are the
ones that people who are familiar with
the bio technological tools from CRISPR
castes are probably familiar with these
include the type 2 systems which use
caste 9 as the effector complex the type
5 systems which use caste 12 or CPF 1 as
the effector complex and the type 6
systems which use caste 13 or c2 c2
which is actually an RNA targeting kass
effector and all of these have been
adapted for various types of
biotechnological purposes so in my lab
we do study the type 2 and type 5
systems but I'm not going to talk about
them today because I want to focus more
on the basic biology of these systems
I'm going to talk today about a type 1
system and you can see that the class
systems in general are quite a bit more
complex in terms of their effect or
complexes than the class two systems so
they are characterized by having
multi-protein effector complexes as
opposed to the single protein effector
complexes that are found in class - so
this is why class two makes for a great
biotechnological tools because they're
much more compact you only have a single
protein as opposed to the multiple
proteins that are present in the
effector complexes of class one so I'm
going to focus today on type one and
specifically I'm going to talk about the
type one system that's found in e.coli
so this is a system called the type 1e
system and the calves effector complex
is found in this system is a large multi
subunit complex called cascade so you
can see a diagram of cascade on the left
along with the castes operon structure
on the top of the slide as well as the
CRISPR
so cascade is made up of five genes that
are shown at the top these are present
in an unequal stoichiometry within the
complex so there's actually six copies
of the caste seven gene and two copies
of the tests or CC two proteins and this
complex very similarly to what I just
described uses a crispr RNA to bind to a
complimentary target using and also
recognizes the target using the pan
sequence so in my lab as I mentioned
earlier we've been interested in the
specificity of the Cascade complex and
in particular we've been interested in
how the target sequence can actually
lead to two different immune responses
so I've talked already about
interference this is what we think of as
a canonical immune response that occurs
when cascade binds to a target and
recruits a separate enzyme
called the cast three nuclease which is
shown here as a purple blob so the cast
three protein in this case is what's
responsible for interference that goes
on to degrade the DNA but in some
situations an alternative response can
actually occur in those situations what
we think happens is that instead of
recruiting cast three alone cascade
recruits cast 3 along with the
adaptation machinery so those proteins
that were involved earlier on in
acquiring a spacer into the CRISPR array
and what happens then is that rather
than degrading the DNA these proteins
together can acquire new spacers into
the CRISPR array and this is what we
think a much more efficient mechanism
for adaptation than any mechanism that
doesn't involve cascade so this process
as opposed to interference is what we
call priming this process that's shown
on the right and is an alternative
immune response that occurs and
especially occurs when there are
mutations present in the target so
mutations within the pam and the seed
are often triggers for priming to occur
so in AI lab we've been asking the
question what determines this functional
outcome and so one of the first things
that we wanted to look at are what types
of mutations so I said Pam and seed
mutations but of course there's many
different types of mutations that can
occur the type of nucleotide that is
that the sequence is changed to as well
as the position of the mutation and so
one of the early experiments that we did
in my lab was to create a screen to test
for either interference or priming when
we have a randomized library of Pam or
seed mutations so what we do
we create a library in this case of Pam
mutations you can see that there's a
trinucleotide pam in this cascade system
we just replaced that pan sequence with
nnn so you have an equal chance of all
four nucleotides at each position so
that's 64 possible sequences we then
transform this library and we transform
the product of this cloning process and
create a plasmid library and this
library serves as the basis for our
activity screen so our activity screen
is actually performed in three separate
strains of E coli in the first strain
this is wild type E coli and in this
strain we expect to see all types of
CRISPR activity so we should see both
interference and priming so one thing to
keep in mind is that because priming
results in a spacer being acquired in
the CRISPR array the target can be lost
from the new spacer that's acquired and
so we should see plasmid loss over time
if either interference or priming occurs
in the second strain the ones shown in
the middle we've deleted cast one casts
one is the gene that's required for
spacer acquisition to occur so in this
strain only interference can occur and
spacer acquisition cannot so priming
cannot occur so in this strain the only
targets that will be lost are the ones
that can undergo interference but the
targets that can undergo priming will
remain abundant in the library the final
strain is a deletion of the CSC one gene
which is the large subunit of Cascade
this subunit is required both for
interference and priming to occur so in
this strain all Christopher targets
should be stable and we use this strain
really as a negative control for the
experiments so we performed this screen
we did this both for a Pam and a seed
library so I'm going to show you the
results of the seed library first this
is actually a simple
library that we use we've repeated these
experiments with more complex libraries
but I'm going to show you the simple
simplified data so in this library we
only had two possible nucleotides at
each position either the correct
nucleotide or an incorrect nucleotide so
you can see the sequences that we used
at the top of the slide and here I'm
plotting sequences with either one
mismatch or two mismatches in the seed
we found that sequences with three or
more mismatches were essentially not
lost in either of the two strains
indicating that three or more mismatches
within the seed are completely deal it
serious to CRISPR castes with human
response either interference or priming
so on the y axis I am plotting the
relative number of counts in the
wild-type strains so these are basically
or we're basically looking at the either
depletion or enrichment of sequences
that may have undergone either
interference or priming on the x-axis
we're looking at the relative counts in
the strain that only went interfere
underwent interference and so what we're
looking for here are basically sequences
that are depleted in either the
interference strain or the strain that
underworlds underwent both interference
and priming and we can see those
sequences in the lower left hand box in
the or basically under the under the
line in the lower left box of the plot
those are sequences that have been
depleted in one or the other strain or
both so we can first of all see that
most of the single mismatch sequences
are highly depleted in both strains
those appear very near the origin of
graph which shows that to some degree
these types of single mismatch sequences
can be tolerated these single mismatches
can be tolerated for CRISPR interference
because they're being lost in the strain
that undergoes both priming and
interference I do want to point out
though that there is a single single
mismatch sequence and for one of the
spacers that we looked at this is a
mismatch at position one and you can see
that this one is not lost for the first
spacer spacer one point one but it is
lost for spacer two point one so what
this shows us is that there's
differences in the effects of mutations
potentially depending on the type of
mismatch or depending on the spacer
sequence you can see conversely that
mismatch at position 4 is d Latrese four
spacer 2.1 but is not problematic for
spacer 1.1 and notably any of or either
of these mismatches in combination with
a second mismatch which are now
highlighted in magenta are are
completely d latias two CRISPR castes
immune response either priming or
interference we were also surprised to
find that there were a couple of double
mismatches that were also tolerated in
some cases so four spacer 1.1 we found
that mismatches at positions 5 & 7 could
be tolerated although this was quite
deleterious for spacer 2.1 conversely
for a spacer 2.1 we saw that mismatches
at positions 2 & 8 are tolerated which
was not tolerated for spacer 1.1 so the
overall message here is that we can see
that depending on potentially the spacer
sequence or the types of mismatches seed
mutations can have very different
effects on whether or not
per interference or priming can occur so
we did the same thing for Pam mutations
and this data I think is actually a
little bit easier to look at in terms of
separating the Pam sequences into
different types of or different groups
so again we see a number of sequences
that are near the origin of the graph
which are shown as blue and these are
the sequences that we think can undergo
interference they were lost in both the
strain that only allows interference to
occur as well as the strain that has
both interference and priming the yellow
sequences are slightly enriched in this
in the strain where only interference
can occur so this indicates that some
priming has sorry that some interference
does occur for these Pam sequences but
in they also undergo priming as they are
depleted more rapidly in the strain that
undergoes both priming and interference
and most interestingly we saw this
purple group of sequences that are high
or just various degrees depleted in the
strain that can undergo priming but are
remain pretty much constant in the
strain that can only undergo
interference these are sequences that we
believe are basically blocking
interference these mutations block
interference but still allow priming to
occur and so I just wanted to point out
a couple of these in particular very
surprisingly I think we saw again
different levels of defects depending on
the spacer sequence so here you can see
that there were three Pam's a AAA a C
and a TA that were essentially
completely lost in both strains for
spacer 1.1 but these strain are these
sequences were only lost to a a much
lesser degree in the
interference strain or space or to point
one so there's um again these spacer
sequence spacer sequence dependent
effects on the mutations and you can see
that again for these other examples and
these examples alright so I want to talk
very briefly about how do these target
mutations alter immune or outcome we
actually think that this is a very
complicated process that's that's
dictated by a number of different
factors so one factor is the binding
affinity and kinetics of the Casa factor
binding to the target so you can see
here we're looking at a simple binding
si so a gel shift assay where when
cascade binds to the DNA it should shift
the DNA slightly due to the change in
the molecular weight of the complex so
this is a run on ax and agarose gel and
you can see that for the a AG pan which
is a canonical Pam a non mutated pan
that you get shifting of the DNA at
around two nano molar of Cascade about
50% shifting at two nano molar you can
see that these four the two spacers that
were looking at the AG Abe ham had
different effects in terms of whether it
fell into a stable group the gray group
or a groups that could undergo
interference or could undergo priming
but not interference so the magenta
group and for the magenta group we can
see that the binding affinity is
slightly affected so as opposed to being
shifted at two shifts at more like ten
so about a five fold defect in binding
affinity whereas four spacer 1.1 where
we have a gray or where it fell into the
[Music]
stable group we don't see shifting at
all so essentially for some reason this
mutation for is the spacer 1.1 C
once kills the binding or the kinetics
of binding by cascade and so we think
one possibility for whether or not
immune response occurs at all or immune
response is shifted from interference to
priming is the effect that the mutation
has on cascade DNA affinity another
thing that we've observed is that
mutations can cause slower interference
so in this case what we're looking at is
a seed mutation this is one of the
mutations that we found does reduce the
activity of cascade in the interfere are
in the interference strain and what we
can see here in this case what we did
was we have a DNA that's been pre bound
by cascade so cascade is already bound
to the target which should eliminate any
binding affinity defects from affecting
the rate at which kes 3 can cleave the
DNA and what we can see is even though
cascade is pre bound to the DNA the rate
of the DNA Exige is significantly slower
for the meet mutated target than it is
for the perfect target so the g1 C
target which has a mutation at the first
position of the seed is cleaved as
degraded much more slowly than the
target that has no mutations in it so
what this shows is that immune outcome
may be affected by the rate of DNA
degradation if you slow the rate of
interference then you'd have more time
for priming to occur because of course
priming is dependent on having the
foreign DNA present in the cell we also
found several sequences that to our
surprise seemed to block interference
altogether so in this case we have a
couple of Pam sequences either the
perfect pam AAG or one of the
Pam's that fell into the magenta group
AGA and what we can see here is that
although the AAG the perfect target is
degraded by s3 following target binding
the AGA pam target is not degraded by KS
3 and this is even though cascade was
pre bound to the plasmid prior to
addition of cast 3 so what this means is
that although cascade can bind to the
target something about the way that
cascade is bound to the target is
blocking kes 3 recruitment and
degradation of the DNA and we've gone on
to show that the basis for this blocking
of target degradation by KS 3 is
actually due to alternate an alternative
conformation of cascade when it's fun to
a target with an AGA pam so this work is
already published I'm not going to talk
about it you can read about it in the
paper that cited on the bottom on the
right but we were able to show that the
CSC one subunit which is responsible for
recruitment of Ches three adopts a
different conformation when there's a
mutation in the pan or in the first
couple nucleotides of the seed and we
believe that this alternative
conformation blocks recruitment of caste
3 and therefore blocks interference and
instead allows for priming to occur all
right so I want to summarize this part
of the talk by telling you about our
first I just want to say to summarize
this slide the immune outcome may be
affected by cascade conformation so just
to summarize I want to say that we've
shown that spacer sequence identity can
affect immune response and this is not
only through the mutation of the
different sequences but we also believe
that depending on the spacer sequence
you can actually have different
responses based on the type of mutation
that occurred so we show I showed you
several examples
of when we compare two different spacers
the same type of mutation has a very
different effect for those two spacers
we believe that target mutations can
alter immune response through multiple
mechanisms we can observe that of course
these mutations will have an effect on
cassadee binding affinity and kinetics
this is to be expected given the fact
that we are altering altering the
sequence that's actually being
recognized surprisingly we can show also
that even if cascade can bind to the
target the rate of degradation can be
severely affected either through slowing
of the cleavage or through complete
blockage of the cleavage and we believe
that this rate of target degradation is
controlled by the confirmation of
cascade one of the interesting ideas I
think that comes out of this type of
research is that we think what might
happen is that some spacers may provide
better defense than others so I've shown
you that different spacer sequences have
or that mutations have different effect
depending on the spacer sequence what
that means is that potentially there are
some types of sequences that may be less
subject to escape mutations than others
if you have say a spacer sequence that
can tolerate more Pama mutations or more
seed mutations it may be a spacer that
is less susceptible to phage escape
because there are fewer mutations that
can potentially lead to that escape so
one of the questions that we're asking
now is whether intrinsic spacer features
can help to combat phage escape another
question that would be interesting to
look into once we're able to actually
define what those intrinsic spacer
features are is whether or not those
better spacers are actually enriched in
nature so you can imagine a couple
different ways in which spacers could be
enriched
one is that spacers that provide better
defense
are preferentially taken up by the
adaptation machinery another is that
bacteria that have these better spacers
are more fit than bacteria that have
spacers that are more prone to phage
escape and so those are the ones that
persist in nature and so if we're able
to define what intrinsic spacer features
lead to better defense we might be able
to look into whether or not those types
of spacers are enriched in nature all
right with that I would like to thank
members of my lab who did this work in
particular chow each way who is a former
graduate student in the lab graduated
last year as well as other members of
the lab who have continued to work on
this project and several other projects
related to CRISPR biology as well as
CRISPR biotechnology I'd also like to
thank Andrew Severn and Erin Seetharam
who are part of the ISU genome
informatics facility who helped with
some of the computational work in
analyzing high-throughput sequencing
data as well as our funding sources and
I'd also like to thank laborat for
giving me the opportunity to present
some of our work to you today and thank
the audience for tuning in and I'm happy
to take any questions
thank you dr. dipali for that
informative presentation we will now
start the Q&A portion of webinar and
we'll address some of the most commonly
asked questions by our viewers if you
have any questions you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question drop-down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
type your question into the box that
appears on your screen and click on the
send button our speaker will follow up
with your questions via email and let's
go first question what implications do
your findings on the differences
sequences have on genome and
applications
so I think the question was what
implications do our findings have on
genome editing applications and I think
that's a really great question so we
found of course that different spacer
sequences can tolerate mutations to a
different level and the flipside of that
when we're talking about genome editing
applications is that if the cast
effector is not that specific then
there's the potential for off targeting
effects during genome editing so if you
had your guide RNA you were targeting it
against a particular gene of interest
and there happened to be another region
somewhere within the genome that had
high homology to your guide RNA then you
have the potential for editing at that
off target site so this is of course one
of the issues with using these TAS
effectors that are intrinsically a
little bit less specific because they've
likely evolved to be able to tolerate
some level of mutation somewhere within
the target in order to kind of stave off
they escape so I think some of the
implications of our work is that there's
the potential that different guide
sequences could have stronger off target
effects because they are more tolerant
of mutations so I talked at the end of
the talk about whether some spacer
sequences are better than others in
terms of providing immunity because they
can provide broader specificity and be
less prone to having escaped mutations
on the flip side of that those same
types of spacers that are have broader
specificity which actually make for
worse guide RNAs for for genome editing
so I think that understanding really
with intrinsic specificity or the
intrinsic sequence features that lead to
these different levels of specificity is
important not only for understanding the
immune response but also for
understanding how we should design guide
or guide RNAs during genome editing
experiments
and how prevalent are crisper caste
systems in nature do all bacteria have
them yeah so that's a very interesting
question actually crisper caste is much
more prevalent in archaea than it is in
bacteria it's found I think in 85 to 90
percent of archaea that have been
sequenced today but there are estimates
that is found and only somewhere between
10 to 40 percent of bacteria so it
really depends on what we're considering
in terms of bacteria
I think it's found in about 40 percent
of bacteria that are culturable and has
been sequenced but if you also look at
uncultured bull so less studied bacteria
they actually tend to be a little bit
the enriched in some cases and the
implications of that are quite
interesting I think and it's a major
open question in CRISPR Cass biology why
are they so prevalent in archaea and why
are they so underrepresented in bacteria
there are I think some pretty obvious
reasons for why CRISPR cows may not be
what that widespread one obvious reason
is that there are actually anti CRISPR
mechanisms so phages have evolved
proteins that can kind of switch off
CRISPR defense mechanisms so these are
proteins that will either bind to the
Casa factor or in the case of the type
one systems they can bind to kes three
and they can basically block the immune
system from actually working
so whether anti crispers are more
prevalent in bacterial stages as a pit
as opposed to the phages that affect
archaea i'm not sure whether that's been
well studied to date but that could be
one reason why bacteria have evolved to
just not have the CRISPR caste systems
because they've been rendered somewhat
useless by these are anti CRISPR systems
another interesting possibility I think
is that CRISPR caste systems can be a
little bit toxic to the cell and one
reason for that is that
there isn't at least as far as we know a
very well defined mechanism for ensuring
that spacers are taken up from the
foreign DNA and that taken up from the
host so I talked earlier about the
toxicity potential toxicity of a Casa
factor if it's too low in its
specificity but another way that they
can be toxic is if you accidentally take
out a spacer from the host DNA so if you
if you take a spacer from the host DNA
then you have a perfect match to
somewhere in the host DNA that will
cleave the host DNA and you'll have
autoimmunity that cell will die so in
some ways having these systems can be a
little bit dangerous to the cell on a
population level it may not matter so
much but if that detriment doesn't
really outweigh the benefits of having
the CRISPR cast system it's possible
that over time the bacteria may have
lost them another possibility although I
think this one is a little bit less less
relevant considering some recent
research is that CRISPR caste systems
limit horizontal gene transfer and you
of course can acquire bacteria can
acquire some very useful genes either
pathogenicity genes or antibiotic
resistance through horizontal gene
transfer so in that way potentially
having the CRISPR caste system can limit
the benefits that could come from
horizontal gene transfer so I think
that's a really interesting question
one that's very much still open in the
field as to why CRISPR Castes systems
are far more prevalent in archaea than
they are in bacteria okay we have time
for one more question you talked about
spacer acquisition but our spacers ever
lost if so how yeah so that is a
question that I get quite often
yeah so spacers are acquired I didn't
really talk about this but spaces are
acquired always at the five prime end of
the CRISPR array and that's a really
interesting mechanism because what that
means is that the most recent memory
that was acquired is the first crispr
RNA that's actually going to be produced
and it's been shown that in fact that
crispr RNA is generally the most
prevalent in the cell and that having
the space required at the beginning of
the array rather than somewhere in the
middle actually does have a much more
beneficial immune outcome so the cells
that have this spacer at the beginning
of the CRISPR array are much more immune
than cells that have the CRISPR
somewhere in the middle of the right and
because the acquisition is polarized in
this manner that means that the spacers
that are towards the three prime end of
the CRISPR array are much older and
could potentially be out of date
especially due to some of the things
that I talked about in my talk today
such as phage escaped so over time
phages are going to evolve it rather
rapidly spacers become sort of defunct
because they no longer have enough
similarity to the target region and
those spacers are the ones that tend to
get lost over time so it's a good
question whether or not spacers can get
lost because if they can't get lost and
you only have space requisition
occurring you're gonna have a larger and
larger CRISPR array and that could
eventually become very cumbersome for
the cell so it has definitely been
observed that spacers are lost and that
they're generally lost from the three
prime end of the CRISPR array
unfortunately I can't answer more than
that we don't know what the mechanism of
how spacers are lost is but my lab has
done some experiments and I think there
are also experiments similar to this
published in the literature that have
shown that if you have a strong negative
selective pressure against having a
spacer
that you can actually have force
basically a bacterial strain to lose
spacers within the CRISPR array and when
those spacers are lost they are lost
perfectly and what I mean by that is
that if you have a space a CRISPR
organization that's basically a repeat
space 2 repeat space or repeat if you
lose a space or you're losing both a
spacer and a repeat which means that you
still continue to have that same
architecture of the CRISPR array so what
we think might be happening is that it's
some kind of replication error and that
basically you can have skipping of
spacers and and repeats due to the
repetitive nature of the CRISPR array so
for some time my lab was trying to look
at whether there's an active mechanism
for losing spacers we haven't been able
to find anything so I think if there
isn't a way that it occurs that it might
just be sort of naturally through these
replication errors
I would like to once again thank dr. de
Polly for her presentation I would also
like to thank libraries for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through January of
2019 you will receive an email from lab
roots letting you know when this webcast
will be available for replay please
share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
event that's all for now thank you for
joining us we hope to see you again soon
goodbye